cette année c'est la deuxième édition de
l'opération sauvons nos monuments pour
contribuer à la sauvegarde du patrimoine
d'ile-de-france et d'oise le journal le
parisien la start-up d'artagnan et la
région ile de france ont déjà
sélectionné 18 projets parmi lesquels
neuf bénéficieront d'une campagne de
financement participatif
il y en aura un par département céline
charles bonsoir soir célia alors dans
les yvelines les internautes devront
choisir entre deux la restauration de
l'église de mézières sur seine et celle
de l'orc de saint-béat iphone et oui en
effet sont deux à vouloir gagner ce
financement en yvelines il n'y a que
quelques kilomètres qui les séparent
mais ils ont chacun leur personnalité
bien distinctes donc le premier candidat
c'est l'orgue de l'église saint béat à
epône ce superbe instrument il nous
vient du facteur d'orgue cavaillé coll
qui date de 1878 même s'il n'a était
arrivé à epône qu en 1901 il dispose de
340 de tuyaux qui repose sur un sommier
et cet orgue il est encore utilisé tous
les dimanches pour les offices alors
quand je suis rentré j'ai été accueilli
par cette petite musique enivrante et
c'est le maire adjoint à la culture
pascal dagory qui nous en parle
e
tout à l'heure on a fait l'expérience de
rentrer dans l'église avec le comment
avec l'orgue qui jouait est fortement 1
et on a pu sentir
palper la musique qui nous tombait
dessus qui nous enveloppait comme un
manteau qui qui faisait que
c'est tout de suite solennelle s'est
tout de suite parce qu'on a une très
belle église qui a une très belle
un très belle acoustique mais cet orgue
à quelques problèmes sincérité et oui en
effet c'est le sommier qui tire de
l'oeil en fait en cause les différentes
canicule qu'ils endommagent pour
l'instant ça s'entend pas encore
vraiment ça pourrait devenir vraiment
catastrophiques si ça devait continuer
la municipalité a jugé le coût des
travaux à 15000 euros le maire nous
expliquent ces travaux qui devraient
durer huit mois où il faut démonter tous
les tous les tuyaux les emmener en
atelier par emmener le sommier un
atelier ur est un des loyers tout ça
mais refaire le sommier comme il faut il
ya un temps de ce sage qui est quand
même relativement important et il ya un
deuxième candidat eh oui le deuxième
candidat c'est l'église saint nicolas à
mézières sur seine c'est une église qui
date du xiiie siècle dont la voûte en
bois étaient financés par françois 1er
elle possède une statue de la vierge à
l'enfant polychrome qui est classé et
une peinture originale d'une confrérie
de charité alors elle est classée au
titre des monuments historiques depuis
1931 le maire de la ville franck
fontaine va nous en parler il met tout
aussi important que de restaurer cette
église qui est le bien culturel le plus
ancien sur notre commune ça reste du
patrimoine
c'est à partir d'un historique ça n'a
pas très loin en effet parfois cultuelle
mais c'est la pierre c'est notre pierse
et c'est ce qui fait aussi eu quand on
passe dans la rue nationale qu'est la
rue commerçante bas on voit cet édifice
qui date du moyen âge et c'est pas ces
panneaux et cette église a besoin aussi
besoin de ce financement en témoigne par
exemple salpêtre c'est une sorte de
petite poudre blanchâtre qui s'attaque
aux enduits des murs les statuts et la
chair par exemple qui nécessite
également un petit ravalement de façade
le manque de chauffage qui oblige
l'église à être fermé en hiver ou encore
les vitraux qui nécessite un petit
petite remise en valeur ses deux larges
travaux qui se feront palier par palier
donc phase par phase le premier
nécessite dix mille euros on écoute
monsieur le maire
l'étrange
dix mille euros c'est pour
l'aider en technique à partir de 15000
euros donc 5000 euros sud est signé on
restaure la chaire partir de vingt mille
euros restaure le le grand tableau qui
fait près de trente trois mètres de long
sur la scène d'enterrement avec la
confrérie de charité et il ya encore
bien des palais à atteindre voilà donc
vous avez jusqu'au 7 novembre le
dimanche 7 novembre pour choisir entre
les deux monuments et c'est sur le site
sauvons nos monuments point fr les sites
s'affiche en bas de l'écran mais alors
oui c'est lille charles pour toutes les
explications